you ever read the the mule [ __ ] in the
beginning
read the beginning i don't want you to
take it away from me yeah
oh god this is so mean
right okay here we go here we go this is
true
oh my god he doesn't know how to spell
allen ginsburg
oh it's about the chest yeah remember i
told you about allen ginsberg
it's real and i thought we i thought you
said ellen yeah
and but you you did spell it out because
i know the guy
yeah you've already said that many times
guys this this entry is not dated
because it is evergreen
alan ginsberg said to me what the [ __ ]
were you writing a novel
this is the [ __ ] you know what i mean
ginsburg said to me
alan allen ginsburg said to me
if i watch too much tv that i might fry
my head
i was hoping for something way more
prophetic than that but okay if i want
if i watch
too much tv that i might fry my head i
wanted to say that i have nothing else
to do with my time
i will not talk about the woman in my
life and their effects on me
no more power to the evil well you're
the original men that go their own way
wow no more
i will not talk about the woman in my
life and their effects on me okay
no more power to the evil time and time
and [ __ ] time again i go through a
[ __ ] phase in my life where i
i mind [ __ ] myself i don't know
people like me i get suspicious of their
judgment
yeah i don't know and character
[Music]
it goes straight into a bus was bombed
in israel
the other day and people dead on the
street
and i complain about my life conflict
and turmoil
globally and i complain i don't vote i
rarely help others and i complain
i [ __ ] like to complain damn it makes
me feel good
i should bring this to her couple's
therapy because you always say i don't
complain
i think that's enough like this is proof
hold on one more one more please just
one more paragraph please
work work work and more [ __ ] work
this minimum wage
drudgery is monotonous and it will kill
me mother said
what mother mother are you mike pence
mother mother mother mother said that i
don't have
any valor where did you talk like this
mother said
i don't have any valor 1970 maybe
she's right oh my god it's such a great
line i have to take a picture of that
okay sad songs really bring me down but
why i don't identify with them the
lyrics usually contain material
or experiences that are foreign to me i
have never had a lover to lose
and my life has been pretty uneventful
the chords are basic
open chords which is usually major and
key i'll never know why sad songs bring
me down but they do
i have seen so many attractive people
today male and female
told you you're a fluid i wonder what
people think of me
what a self-sent what a self-centered
thought i need to face
and walk through my fear i'm so close
and yet so far away
i lit up a cigarette in front of a
non-smoking person and she started to
complain
don't you know that that secondhand
smoke can kill me you selfish bastard
you know i don't like when people break
out hard drugs like cocaine crack it's
just a personal thing
so i developed a technique when i find
myself in those situations what i do is
what i
is i leave okay
there's a lot of good advice to yourself
yeah babe
anyway what a weird episode wait i wanna
let's let's let's
let's retract i really wanna do a recap
of what everyone's done in the holidays
before we wrap up no no
i'm not wrapping up yeah i just don't
want to talk about this anymore i think
it's it's it's like it's so is it
emotionally draining
for me it gets weird i i was scared
you know and that's also it's like i was
a little a lot more like
introspective i think
and and and and you know just to journal
i think you you seem a lot
more focused like not
as kind of all over the place
yeah but there was always like this um
notes from the underground
the real reason why i had a journal is
because you know i just wanted to like
you know
um because i was so alone
all the time right you don't really have
a lot of friends and you're and so
depressed and just walking around
and being very like
you know when you're at that age there's
a very philosophical i guess you know i
mean trying to find the meaning of life
or whatnot
and i would just write you know in an
introspective kind of a way but i i
maybe i should start journaling again i
think that you should yeah
i mean i started journaling during the
pandemic i'll bring that next time
you've been drilling your whole life
though right oh yeah i journaled a lot
but again
very similar to his super emo like i
would cut myself and then put the blood
on my journal
what oh yeah yeah i would listen to
[ __ ] fiona apple's rendition
of across the universe love that song um
but her rendition's like super
depressing i know that i know i love
that version
yeah and then i would always just you
know yeah we're the same baby
him and i would have gotten along we
would have probably what shirt is that
red scare it's a great show red scare
yeah what's word scare
uh it's a podcast on patreon
very good